ever wonder why Sesame Streets count Von
count counts the number of the day is
four vampires exist in countless
cultures dating back Millennia and while
some common characteristics turn up
across lore there are some more regly
and culturally specific claims like the
compulsive need to count in some Chinese
folklore people sprinkle a handful of
rice across a threshold to distract an
arithmomania vampire a similar tradition
exists in Romania except it's milit
that's thrown Across The Vamps path with
the idea that they'll have to stop mid
hunt to count the seeds thus buying the
hum some time to get away hopefully in
some places in Eastern Europe it's said
you can even stop a vampire from rising
in the first place by filling their
coffin with sand or poppy seeds got to
love a little monster Lord Easter egg in
a kids show thanks count